Wir sind on air, wie man so schön sagt. Herzlich willkommen. Grüße aus der Ebene META-Ebene. Willkommen bei einem neuen Experiment namens Logbuch Netzpolitik. Ich bin Tim Pritlove und mir gegenüber sitzt Linus. Hallo.
Hallo.
Linus Neumann. Wir sitzen hier und ganz jinglefrei, wie sich das so gehört für eine erste Ausgabe eines Podcasts. Versuchen wir hier erst mal eine kleine Standortbestimmung zu machen. Vielleicht kurz erst mal ganz allgemein was zu der Idee. Neben vielen Podcasts, die in der META-Ebene entstehen, die ja in der Regel epische Länge haben, fehlt so ein bisschen das regelmäßige und aktuelle. Das war zumindest mein Gefühl. Und das Logbuch soll diese Lücke ein wenig füllen. Das heißt, könnte sein, dass es hier auch noch mehrere Varianten gibt. Logbuch Netzpolitik soll jetzt schon mal die dringendste Lücke schließen, nämlich der Versuch, einen Überblick zu bekommen über was sich so bewegt in diesem etwas diffizil abzusteckenden Bereich, der, glaube ich, auch mit dem Begriff Netzpolitik nur schwer zu beschreiben ist. Weiß nicht, ist dir schon mal was besseres eingefallen?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Also es gibt immer sehr vielleicht ganz spannende Begriffe, die man da vielleicht für versuchen kann zu verwenden, aber die dann auch eigentlich immer per se schon komplett abgedroschen sind.
Ja, auf jeden Fall soll es um Politik gehen oder um generell die Politik vielleicht beeinflussenden Ereignisse. Und wie es eben so unser Fokus ist, vor allem all das, was mit dem Netz zu tun hat, was mit dem Digitalen zu tun hat. Vielleicht könnte man auch sagen, was mit dem Neuen zu tun hat, aber jetzt Forum für neue Politik oder so ein Quatsch.
Internet und digitale Gesellschaft.
Ja, das lassen wir jetzt einfach mal offen. Die Idee ist hier im Idealfall wöchentlich, vielleicht manchmal auch nur zweiewöchentlich, wie es die Zeit zulässt zusammenzukommen. Und ein wenig darüber zu zenieren, was so passiert ist. Und von daher auch ein Medium zu schaffen, in dem man dranbleiben kann. Ich bemerke das auch selber an mir immer wieder, so sehr einen das interessiert, so sehr man sich auch als Teil des Ganzen empfindet. Man hat ja auch noch ein anderes Leben. Und es ist immer sehr schwierig, diesen Diskussionen zu folgen. Es gibt natürlich eine ganze Reihe von Protagonisten, die ist da, die steckt da irgendwie drin. Die sind da halt irgendwann mal in den Topf gefallen, müssen da gar keinen Namen nennen. Und die, denke ich, erleben das Ganze dann auch schon so ein bisschen in ihrer eigenen Blase und sehen Dinge dann auch mal als selbstverständlich an und wundern sich, wenn die Öffentlichkeit nicht folgen kann, wenn es auch nur so die Teilöffentlichkeit des wohl informierten Netzes, die Twitterianer oder andere selbsternannten Eliten betrifft. Das ist schon ein Problem, oder?
Ich gebe das auch relativ freimütig zu, dass ich dazu zähle, wahrscheinlich zu diesem Personenkreis, der da inzwischen vielleicht sich über Debatten oder Probleme Gedanken macht, die vielleicht der Gesellschaft oder die nicht so allgemein vermittelbar sind. Ich merke das teilweise, wenn ich dann mit Menschen mich unterhalte, die fragen, was machst du so? Und ich sage, ich schreibe zum Beispiel auch bei netzpolitik.org. Und dann, ja, was ist das denn, was macht ihr denn da? Und dann muss man sich irgendwie wirklich bemühen, zu erklären, was das für Themen sind, womit man sich damit befasst. Und dann kommt immer, ja, mach mal ein Beispiel. Und dann wird es halt echt haarig. Dann wird es schwierig wirklich zu erklären, warum setze ich mich jetzt gerade genau damit auseinander? Und weswegen ist eine Debatte zwischen diesen beiden Personen jetzt gerade für mich interessant oder für diese Gesellschaft relevant? Und was wir hier versuchen wollen, ist das so ein bisschen, also diese Ebene so ein bisschen reinzubringen, dadurch, dass man da vielleicht eine Kontinuität reinbringt und dass man auch den Hörer davon entbindet, so viele Texte dazu lesen zu müssen, um dann den Einstieg und das Verständnis so ein bisschen zu fördern.
Genau. Und auch so ein bisschen zu versuchen, so etwas komplexe Sachverhalte, wo man einfach auch zu viel lesen müsste, ja, Debatten etc. so ein bisschen zusammenzufassen. Da, wo wir vielleicht auch selbst da nicht kundig genug sind, wenn wir dann vielleicht hier und da auch mal noch eine weitere Person mit hineinnehmen, aber im Kern. Und wir die beiden, mit denen ihr es jetzt erstmal aushalten müsst. Ja, Linus, wir hatten ja vor kurzem schon mal die Freude hier länger über das Thema zu reden. Da ging es konkret um die digitale Gesellschaft, die sich gegründet hatte. Auf der Republika ausgerufen, gab es dann eben auch gleich so diese etwas verschwitzte Diskussion in der Netzgemeinde, die ja dann auch...
Dürfen die das?
Dürfen die das, genau, und was wollen die eigentlich? Und da kann ja jeder kommen und so weiter. Das ist halt immer so ein Problem, wenn man was Neues anfängt, aber schon mit irgendeiner Reputation ins Feld geht. Die Aufregung hat sich auch deutlich gelegt. Ich fand bloß das Gespräch ganz gut, was wir da geführt haben, weil es eben noch mal ganz gut zusammengelegt hat, was auch so die Probleme sind in dieser ganzen Aktivisten-Geschichte. Also viele Leute vertreten irgendwelche Thesen, teilweise eben auch sehr schwer atmend. Und man regt sich immer gerne auf. Das ist ja auch so ein Phänomen, gerade so in dieser Twitteria, da ist halt so das Empörungspotenzial ist halt immer sehr groß. Aber wenn man dann eben mal an die Aktivisten herantritt und sagt, ja, was macht ihr denn so, außer euch zu empören? Wenn ihr irgendwie nur zehn Prozent der Energie, die ihr in die Empörung stecken würdet, mal in anführungsstrichen langweilige Dinge stecken würdet, wie hier mal jemand anrufen oder da mal, keine Ahnung, irgendwas anderes kluges tun, dann würde sich das schon ändern. Aber das ist natürlich auch das Problem. Es ist sehr viel einfacher, sich zu empören. Ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht so schlecht machen, weil auch das Empören gehört ein bisschen dazu. Diese ganze Zensursolar-Geschichte hat am Ende auch durch diese kollektive Empörung natürlich auch eine Kraft entwickelt. Auch natürlich, weil dann eben auch viele Leute konkret was getan haben, weil dann die Petition losgetreten wurde, Demos zusammengerufen wurden, Schilder gemalt etc., all das. Beides ist also wichtig. Trotzdem wohlinformierte Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, hängt natürlich vor allem immer an dieser Wohlinformation. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht den Anspruch, dass wir jetzt hier die Wahrheit verkünden, aber wir wollen auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen Diskussionsforum sein. Vielleicht können wir ja auch was machen, was ich so noch nicht gemacht habe, dass wir auch Redebeiträge uns schicken lassen. Also wenn jemand einen Kommentar zu irgendeiner Situation hat, den er natürlich im Blog hinterlassen kann, aber das eben auch vielleicht mal aufnehmen möchte, so vielleicht nicht unbedingt in epischer Breite, aber so einfach als gesprochener Kommentar, warum nicht, können wir glaube ich ganz offen mit umgehen. Und wie schon erwähnt eben auch vielleicht so mal ein Interview live oder jemand mit dazu nehmen. Insgesamt wollen wir es auch nicht so episch lang halten. Wir haben noch uns nicht so richtig auf irgendwas einigen können, wie lang das sein soll, aber ja knapp.
Wir wollen unter einer Stunde glaube ich auf jeden Fall sein.
Genau, ob uns das jetzt heute so gelingt, weiß ich noch nicht so genau. Aber ich denke, das Wesentliche zusammenfassend, vor allem wenn man es regelmäßig macht, das lässt sich eigentlich auch in einer halben Stunde realisieren. Und wir werden dann auch, jetzt sitzen wir hier mal zusammen im Studio, aber ich denke mal, häufig wird es auch so sein, dass wir eben uns nur über Skype fangen können. Das geht dann auf Kosten der Qualität, aber zugunsten der Aktualität. Ja, so viel vielleicht mal so als allgemeiner Einstieg. Was ist denn so, ich dachte, da wir jetzt nichts haben, wo wir sagen können, naja, letzte Woche haben wir ja darüber gesprochen. Da müssen wir jetzt erstmal hier so ein bisschen so eine Basislinie legen. Du hast ja schon erwähnt, du schreibst bei Netzpolitik, das heißt, du bist ja schon auch in gewisser Hinsicht so ein Begleiter. Seit längerer Zeit. Und ich mach auch immer so Erfahrungen, also wenn man über irgendwas ausführlich bloggt und da auch mehr als eine Bildschirmsite füllt, dann hat man sich das wahrscheinlich schon etwas genauer angeschaut, als ob man jetzt nur dem Empör-Stream joint.
Ja, es muss natürlich auch jeden Tag eine neue Sau durchs Twitter getrieben werden. Ja, das ist, finde ich, ist ja auch eigentlich ganz schön. Und man kann natürlich auch, es gibt ja auch genug Leute und auch genug Futter für die These, dass das auch wichtig ist, dass sich Leute empören. Also wenn wir uns nicht empören würden über vielleicht bestimmte Dinge, wie sieht es dann aus? Ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass so eine, wie teilweise im Netz sich empört wird und vor allem in der in der geschriebenen, im geschriebenen Wort, das geht teilweise, nimmt das da, also glaube ich, dass da Konflikte einen Feuer erreichen, auch zwischen Protagonisten, was vielleicht gar nicht so in der Form unbedingt da sein müsste. Also auch insbesondere vielleicht auch mal unter einzelnen Vertretern, wie wir das ja in letzter Zeit auch mal gesehen haben. Weiß nicht, ob wir da heute noch zukommen.
Ja, warum nicht? Also ich meine, das ist ja auf jeden Fall etwas, was sich in den letzten Wochen auch mal da abgezeichnet hat. Du meinst wahrscheinlich hier diese Auseinandersetzung zwischen Alvar und anderen.
Alvar hat groß einen abbekommen vor ein paar Wochen. Bei der Thematik der Vorratsdatenspeicherung wurde er dann kritisiert für seine Position.
Also wir reden von Alvar Freude, wer hier noch keinen Personen-Einblick hat. Vielleicht die Leute auch mal ein bisschen erklären. Genau, das wollen wir nämlich auch machen, dass wir vielleicht die Personen auch mal ein bisschen vorstellen, die hier eine Rolle spielen. Dass wir hier nicht nur von Insidern zu Insidern reden.
Alvar Freude, ein Netzaktivist seit sicherlich zehn Jahren. Ich glaube, erstmalig bekannt oder...
Zehn Jahre, ich glaube, viel länger schon.
Ja, also klar, er geht irgendwie zurück auf... Er geht, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich zurück bis ins Usenet. Aber bekannt seit spätestens seit zehn Jahren durch die Online-Demonstration Lufthansa. Das war, glaube ich, das erste Mal, wo Alvar wirklich ganz groß in Erscheinung getreten ist.
Naja, auch so seine experimentellen, fast künstlerischen Projekte am Anfang, mit Zensurfiltern etc. Das geht ja schon sehr lange zurück. Also Alvar ist da schon immer engagiert gewesen. Und in dem Maße, wie sich das insgesamt politisiert hat, hat er sich da so mit politisiert.
Und du sagtest gerade schon, sein wichtiges großes, oder eines seiner großen Themen Zensur, der sich sehr ausführlich mit befasst. Ich denke, dass seine Abschlussarbeit jetzt... Ich hoffe, dass ich seinen Grad jetzt nicht verwechsel, aber ich glaube, es war seine Diplomarbeit, handelte ja auch mit so einem Zensur- oder Content-... Von einem Zensur- oder Content-Veränderungsfilter. Und ist ein sehr wichtiges Mitglied, wenn nicht das wichtigste Mitglied des AK Zensur, der sich gegen Zensurmaßnahmen in jeder Art im Netz richtet, sei es durch das Sperren von bestimmten Seiten, Inhalten oder sonstigen Dingen. Und ist unter anderem für die SPD, der als Sachverständiger in der CAT-Kommission Internet und digitale Gesellschaft und auch im SPD-Bereich Gesprächskreis Netzpolitik aktiv. Und da hatte sich dann die Position herausgebildet zur Frage der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Vertritt Alvar seit einiger Zeit, solange ich weiß, dass er eine Position zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat, vertritt er die Position, dass es in Ordnung sei, wenn IP-Adressen gespeichert werden. Das heißt, bei dem Provider soll gespeichert werden. Linus Neumann kommt ins Internet rein, war dann von dann bis dann mit seinem Anschluss verbunden und hatte die IP so und so. Was dann, wenn an anderen Stellen diese IP auffällt, als jemand, der gegen das Gesetz verstoßen hat, das heißt, ich schreibe irgendwo einen Beitrag in einen Blog, der irgendwie strafrechtlich oder gesetzlich irgendwie rechtlich relevant ist, oder ich werde dabei nachweislich ertappt, mich an einer Tauschbörse beteiligt zu haben, dort eine urheberrechtlich geschützte Datei verbreitet zu haben, dass dann quasi mittels dieser IP-Adresse wie ein Autokennzeichen es möglich wird, mich zurück zu verfolgen, diese IP-Adresse zurück zu verfolgen zum Anschlussinhaber. Hat natürlich dann immer noch das Problem, dass es immer nur nachgewiesen ist, welcher Anschluss es war, und noch nicht, dass ich auch tatsächlich an dem Rechner saß, für die Ermittlungsbehörden oder für die Justiz. Aber das war die Position, die da erarbeitet wurde, zu sagen, okay, unter Berücksichtigung einerseits Datenschutz und andererseits Möglichkeiten zur Strafverfolgung halten wir es für einen vernünftigen Kompromiss, wenn IP-Adressen gespeichert werden. Das heißt also, was nicht gespeichert wird, was ja in der ursprünglichen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die wir hatten, war ja dann, weiß nicht, wer hat wann, mit wem kommuniziert, E-Mails geschrieben, welche Seiten habe ich wann, wo aufgerufen. Also das war ja eher so, da sollte ja so die vollumfassende Vorratsdatenspeicherung eher stattfinden. Das heißt, davon ein größerer Schritt zurück. Und da gab es dann, glaube ich, vor allem deshalb Konflikte, weil viele Personen, inklusive mir häufiger, den AK Vorrat, der sich mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und den AK Zensur, der sich mit der Zensur auseinandersetzt, natürlich auch teilweise überschneidende Mitglieder hat, verwechselt haben. Sodass dann Alvar als großer Verräter an der Idee, der des Kämpfens gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gesehen wurde, weil man irgendwie meinte, der ist doch im AK Vorrat. Ja, da ist er aber nicht drin. Er ist halt im AK Zensur und hat zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung eben diese Position, die er da entfaltet hat. Und da gab es eine ganze Menge Personen, die weil Alvar eben, also jemand ist, der in diesem Feld so bekannt ist, dass wenn er etwas sagt, dann wird das gehört. Das wird wahrgenommen, der ist als Sachverständiger anerkannt und dem hören die Menschen zu. Dass da Leute sich sehr groß beklagt haben darüber, dass er ausgerechnet Alvar jetzt so eine Position hat. Da gab es dann größere Streitereien.
Geschrei.
Da gab es längere Wochen großes Geschrei.
Mit irgendeinem Ergebnis eigentlich?
Das Geschrei hat ja selten ein Ergebnis. Ich glaube, was man jetzt überlegen kann, das Ergebnis war auf jeden Fall, dass er nicht die Gelegenheit hatte, seine Idee da vernünftig zu verteidigen. Man kann da auch Namen nennen. Wer ihn da groß angegriffen hat, war Fefe, der mit relativ kurzen, der ja einen Blog führt, was eher mit sehr wenigen Sätzen immer auskommt.
Also Felix von Leitner.
Felix von Leitner, ein Mitglied des Chaos Computer Clubs, der ein sehr vielgelesenes Blog unterhält, indem er sich nicht unbedingt, also indem er mit kurzen, prägnanten Sätzen zu gewissen Themen Stellung nimmt.
Und dabei auch stark polarisiert.
Ja, der nimmt einmal eine, also nimmt sehr häufig eine sehr klare Position ein, die durchaus in vielen Fällen provokativ ist. Er ist aber deswegen, er ist halt sehr geschickt, weil er das mit sehr kurzen Sätzen macht und Alva war in diesem Fall sehr ungeschickt, weil Alva nicht dazu neigt, sich in kurzen Sätzen auszudrücken. Alva ist jemand, der eher dazu neigt, einen sehr langen Text zu schreiben oder einen sehr langen Redebeitrag zu leisten. Was jetzt die inhaltlich natürlich auch, also es gibt einen Grund, warum er so viel sagt. Ja, das ist nicht alles nur heiße Luft, sondern er erklärt halt sehr ausführlich. Aber das ist natürlich in so einer Netzdebatte, wenn das da kocht, ist er da einfach strukturell unterlegen. Wenn Fefe ihm irgendwie fünf Sätze an den Kopf knallt und Alva schreibt fünf Seiten zurück, ist klar, wer den Treffer gelandet hat. Und es ist natürlich auch ganz klar, dass viele dann diese langen Texte gar nicht mehr lesen. Und da hatten wir dann eine sehr heikle Debatte, oder sehr heiße Debatte. Ist aber jetzt auch schon wieder einige Wochen her. Hat aber leider, es war so ein bisschen schmerzlich, weil Alva auf jeden Fall viel Engagement für die gute Sache gezeigt hat. Ich will gar nicht unbedingt sagen, ob ich jetzt mit ihm persönlich da übereinstimme oder nicht. Das spielt keine Rolle. Was ich daran so schmerzhaft fand, war, dass diese Debatte absolut fernab von jeder sachlichen oder inhaltlichen Überlegung war. Das ist glaube ich das Einzige, was...
Es war eigentlich nur so Verräter oder nicht?
Genau, ein Verräter ist ein Verräter. Es ist ja sowieso die SPD wird ja... Ist ja die Verräterpartei.
Das hat sich ja bei dieser Zin-Sosala-Debatte als Kampfparole herausgeschält. Was ich damals als absolut legitime Kampfpropaganda auch angesehen habe in der Hinsicht, als dass sie eben klargemacht hat, was glaube ich an der Stelle auch mittlerweile sich schon so ein bisschen in die Politikdiskussion mit hinein übersetzt, so dieses bei seinen Aussagen bleiben. Und nicht immer, kaum bin ich in der Regierung, ist alles anders. Dass das eben auch wahrgenommen und bewertet und beobachtet wird. Das ist, glaube ich, so eine, weiß nicht, ob das was Neues ist, aber der Grad an Beobachtung nimmt zu. Durch Twitter, durch diese ganze öffentliche Diskussion, durch Sachen wie Abgeordneten-Watch etc. Also diese immer gewünschte Transparenz. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie bereits hergestellt worden ist, aber es gibt Anzeichen, dass sich die Politik in zunehmenden Maße an einem Punkt beobachtet fühlt, wo sie bisher glaubt, wurscht hinzu können. Hat sich auch mit Gutenberg etc. gezeigt, dass da einfach so ein paar Schutzräume, die früher als gegeben angesehen wurden, so ein bisschen weggefallen sind.
Ja, es gibt immer mehr öffentliches Interesse, oder insbesondere im Bereich der Netzpolitik natürlich, weil sie ja diese Öffentlichkeit, diese Twitter- und Blog-Öffentlichkeit natürlich auch konkret betrifft. Da gibt es natürlich eine sehr große Aufmerksamkeit, die da auf den Politikern lastet. Aber ich dachte eigentlich, dass dieses Verräter-Partei, ich kenne das noch, dieses Wer hat uns verraten Sozialdemokraten, das geht ja noch, also der Verrat hat eine lange Geschichte.
Aber ich würde sagen, darauf war es eher eine lustige Anspielung. Und dass man es in dem Fall dann eben wirklich so gesehen hat, mit hier Zensur und so, da müsste es irgendwie, ihr müsst jetzt auch einfach mal Stellung beziehen. Und ihr könnt euch da nicht immer rumeiern und glauben, das wäre jetzt ein Thema, was von der Öffentlichkeit her nicht wahrgenommen wird. Und es wird wahrgenommen. Und seitdem ist ja auch eine Menge passiert, wie man so einen Hinblick auf Piratenpartei, etc. sieht.
Genau, auf Piratenpartei.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf die Piratenpartei direkt kommen, aber ich denke, dass auch noch ein anderes Thema jetzt hier an der Stelle auch ganz gut passt, gerade was so diese inner-szenenlichen Auseinandersetzungen betrifft. Neben Vorratsdaten, Speicherung und Zensur, denke ich mal, ist auch immer wieder vielleicht das schwammigste Diskussionsfeld überhaupt ist der Bereich Datenschutz, Privatsphäre, Datenschutz. Einerseits mega schwammig, weil glaube ich sehr unterschiedliche Vorstellungen davon existieren, was man denn nun eigentlich wirklich erreichen möchte. Und dass es auch alle Lager zu geben scheint, also so von den voll fundamentalisten, die am liebsten mit einer schwarzen Kapuze über dem Kopf nie aufgenommen, nie irgendwie getreckt werden wollen, die in vollständiger Anonymität ihr Dasein fristen. Auf der anderen Seite wollen oder davon träumen, dass es ja so eigentlich zu sein habe oder so. Dem gegenüber stehen dann selbst berufene Realisten, die darauf verweisen, dass das ja eh alles Quatsch sei, da die Technik sich nun mal so weiterentwickelt und man ja viel gegen Kameras haben kann, aber nichts daran ändern wird, dass sie einfach da sein werden und dass man ja doch irgendwie damit leben müsste mit dieser Öffentlichkeit. Und dann könnte man es ja dann auch gleich so provokativ nach außen tragen, dass man sein ganzes Leben geradezu in jedes nur erdenkliche Social Network in allen möglichen Datenbankdetails hineingießt und so. Ja, das sind diese mega Extreme und dazwischen spielt sich natürlich sehr viel anderes ab.
Was man vielleicht zu den Offenheitsextremisten noch sagen soll, nicht nur, dass sie sagen, man könnte das auch gleich machen, sondern dass sie auch davon ausgehen, dass das ausschließlich positive Effekte für die Gesellschaft haben wird. Die Idee ist ja, wenn wir alle nackt sind, dann hat keiner mehr irgendwie, dann ist das auch nicht mehr peinlich und dann haben wir Vorteile dadurch.
Digitale Freikörperkultur sozusagen.
Genau, da gibt es im Moment ein Themenfeld, wo man auch so zum ersten Mal sieht, wo sich diese, ich nehme jetzt mal diesen abgedorschten Begriff Netzgemeinde, wo es wirklich, das ist glaube ich das ein, das Themenfeld, wo man wirklich sieht, da können die sich echt spalten. Da kann zum ersten Mal wirklich eine richtige Spaltung in diesen Gruppen, die einerseits zwar gemeinsam dann dastehen. Vorratsdatenspeicherung finden glaube ich auch die Post-Privacy-Freunde, also diejenigen, die sagen, die Privatsphäre ist vorbei, wir müssen uns auf eine Gesellschaft vorbereiten oder wir wollen eine Gesellschaft haben, in der Privatsphäre keine Kategorie mehr ist, weil alles öffentliches Interesse ist. Also Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist glaube ich was dagegen, die sich trotzdem dann wehren, also auf jeden Fall sehe ich die jeweiligen Protagonisten bei den Demos dann doch. Also bei vielen Dingen ist sich diese Netzgemeinde eben doch sehr einig und ergeht sich dann vielleicht auch mal in kleineren Detaildebatten, wie wir gerade schon erwähnt hatten. Und bei dieser Datenschutzsache ist das echt so, dass man da jetzt wirklich beobachtet, dass es da gibt es dann wirklich Fundamentalisten, die gehen da wirklich diametral in ganz unterschiedliche Richtungen. Und da könnte so eine Spaltung stattfinden. Wobei ich persönlich, das werde ich wahrscheinlich im Laufe der Folgen zu diesem Thema, ich halte das nicht unbedingt für so einen großen Widerspruch. Also ich glaube, dass die Front, die da gerade zwischen Post-Privacy-Kämpfern oder Apologeten oder wie auch immer man sie nennen möchte und Datenschützern aufgespannt wird. Ich glaube nicht, dass die im Moment ein bisschen so diametral gegenüberstehen, diese Positionen.
Weil am Ende ist das nur eine mediale Inszenierung? Die Szene wurde als spaltbar angesehen und jetzt kommen sie und müssen ihre Gelegenheit?
Es gibt ja zum Beispiel dieses Buch von Frank Riga, auch ein Sprecher des Chaos Computer Club und Constanze Kurz, ebenfalls eine Sprecherin des Chaos Computer Club, die zusammen ein Buch geschrieben haben, die Datenfresser, heißt das glaube ich, indem sie ausführen, wie die Gesellschaft durch alle möglichen Unternehmen, Facebooks, Googles und Staaten und alle irgendwie überwacht wird. Und was zum Beispiel mal die Leser darüber aufgeklärt, was eben das Geschäftsmodell von Webseiten ist, die Dienste kostenlos anbieten. Um es kurz zu sagen, wenn dir der Dienst kostenlos angeboten wird, dann bist du nicht der Kunde, sondern dann bist du das Produkt. Das ist mal so oft die Spitze zu treiben, weil diese Firmen natürlich mit den Daten, die man dort eingibt, diese Daten nutzen, um sie irgendwie zu Geld zu machen. Da haben sie ja ein sehr langes Buch darüber geschrieben. Und darin wird die These vertreten, dass diese Post-Privacy-Bewegung im Prinzip sich instrumentalisieren lässt, um diese Geschäftsmodelle zu legitimieren. Und gleichzeitig denke ich aber, dass eigentlich diese, also alle Leute, die jetzt also diese Post-Privacy, diesen Post-Privacy-Gedanken irgendwie anhängen und ihn pflegen, dass die eigentlich genauso wenig ein Interesse daran haben sollten, dass es eine große zentrale Datenbank gibt, in der alles ist. Also wenn sie davon ausgehen, dass die Gesellschaft von dieser Offenheit profitieren soll, dann geht mit dieser Theorie eigentlich auch einher, dass alle den gleichen Zugriff auf diese Daten haben. Und damit sollten eigentlich Post-Privacy-Freunde genauso sich gegen eine zentralistische Struktur wie Facebook wenden, wie Datenschützer. Das ist jetzt so meine These. So dass eigentlich für Post-Privacy-Personen es genau ebenso interessanter wäre, wenn ein soziales Netzwerk dezentral und in Nutzerhand ist und da auf Augenhöhe die Personen agieren und nicht ein zentrales Unternehmen die gesamten Daten hortet und als geistiges Eigentum betrachtet und solche Dinge. Also ich denke, dass da ein Anknüpfungspunkt zwischen beiden ist, weil die Datenschützer ja hauptsächlich, die Hauptsorge des Datenschutzes ja eigentlich ist, dass zentral Daten gespeichert werden. Nur so verstehe ich Datenschutz hauptsächlich, dass man sagt, man möchte eine Datensparsamkeit haben grundsätzlich, dass nicht so viel gespeichert wird und vor allem die Grundidee des Datenschutzes denke ich war, oder eine der Grundideen ist, dass es nicht große zentrale Ansammlungen gibt, nicht große zentrale Register und ich denke, das ist also ein Punkt, wo sich Datenschützer und Post-Privacy-Freunde begegnen können. Begegnen sollten. Ich habe das auch schon mal ausprobiert mit dem Christian. Jetzt heller. Plom Lompom auf Twitter. Einer, der jetzt auch relativ bald ein Buch zu seinen Post-Privacy-Gedanken veröffentlicht.
Ist es nicht schon drauf? Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe nur gelesen, dass Leute es gelesen haben, aber es kann natürlich sein, dass sie irgendwelche Vorab-Exemplare genossen haben.
Mir wurde eines versprochen, wenn... also ich bin beleidigt. Ach so.
Ich nehme mir alles zurück, wenn ich das falsch interpretiert habe. Ich dachte, ein paar Tweets so... also MS-Pro schrieb irgendwas davon, aber der Magne wirklich nochmal extra Zugriff haben. Aber wir können ja mal kurz gucken hier. Ja, wie heißt denn das Buch? Nein? Ich auch nicht.
Also ich wusste es sicherlich mal.
Er fragt, ob irgendjemand schon mal postalisch das Buch angekommen sei. Lies er aber bei Amazon auf sich warten. Okay, also wir befinden uns offensichtlich gerade im Zustand der Veröffentlichung. So der unmittelbar bevorstehenden nutzt hier den Hashtag postprivacy-Buch. Vielleicht heißt es ja auch so. Weiß ich aber nicht.
Ich glaube schon, dass ihm da noch ein besserer Teller gefällt.
Hier gibt es eine Webseite dazu. Postprivacy, prima Leben ohne Privatsphäre.
Genau, das war's.
Mit iPhone auf dem Cover. Beck Verlag. CH Beck Facebook und Co. Privatsphäre ist ein Auslaufmodell, Datenschutz, ein Kampf gegen Windmühlen. Unser Sein und Handeln wird gespeichert, berechnet, ausgewertet. Wir müssen lernen, damit klarzukommen. Privatsphäre war eh Niederlupen, reine Wohltäter, als der sie gern dargestellt wird. Mit ihrem Wegfall im digitalen Zeitalter ergeben sich nicht nur viele neue Probleme, sondern auch viele neue Chancen. Sogar die Kurztäter hier, das Kolophon dieses Buchs. Interessant finde ich in dem Absatz die alte Kernabwägung, die auch der CCC ja eigentlich von Anfang an immer vorangestellt hat, Chancen und Risiken der IT oder generell des Einsatzes von Technik abwägen. Chancen und Risiken sehen. Bisweilen habe ich so den Eindruck, dass bestimmte Gruppen sich doch sehr viel mehr wieder mit den Risiken auseinandersetzen und dass das Gewarne sehr viel mehr Raum einnimmt, als das Ausarbeiten der möglichen Chancen. Das ist nur so ein Gefühl, das mag auch nicht auf jeden jetzt zutreffen und ich meine das ist jetzt auch gar nicht so ein Vorwurf, dass ich der Meinung bin, man müsste ja jetzt unbedingt mehr das andere machen. Risiken sind natürlich immer vorhanden und vor allem ist es ja auch immer so, man tritt sich ja mit Technologie schnell was ein. Hat man erst mal damit eingefangen, das ist ja dieser Klassiker bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, haben wir die erst mal, dann ist das Missbrauchspotenzial von Tag eins so enorm und man weiß vor allem, wenn es das erst mal gibt, ist das selbst, wenn man danach alle Risiken erkennt, fast wieder un-zurückbaubar und deswegen ist es natürlich klar, dass man in Bezug auf die Risiken schnell mal hyperventiliert und die Sachen auch dramatisiert und sich mehr darauf konzentriert. Auf der anderen Seite hat man ja auch diese Facebook-Welt, die Firmenwelt, die natürlich immer schnell dabei ist, die Verheißungen der modernen Technik zu singen, wenn es sich nicht gerade um die Buch- oder Musikbranche oder Filmbranche handelt, die sich auch irgendwie auf die Risiken konzentriert, aber irgendwie an einer anderen Stelle, wo die anderen Vertreter eben meinen, dass dort mehr Chancen liegen, also es ist wirklich ein ganz schönes Durcheinander. Ja, da bin ich ja mal dann gespannt, wie diese Debatte weitergeht. Zwei Stichworte haben wir in dem Zusammenhang nicht genannt oder du bist zumindest gut drum herum gestiefelt. Es hat sich ja dann auch so eine Gruppe gebildet, die Spackeria, wo man dann erst mal sich fragt, was denn das für ein Name, das geht ja dann zurück auf so eine, naja Beschimpfung auf einem Chaos-Communication-Kongress, ich glaube Constanza war es, die es losgetreten hat, war hier die Post-Privacy-Spacken und dann kam halt das so als Gay Pride-mäßig, so Proud to be Spack, hat sich dann eben schnell so eine Gruppe gefunden, wo sich dann auch die Medien drauf gestürzt haben, weil da waren dann auch Frauen, auch noch die Apologeten auf beiden Seiten und so, das ist natürlich ganz was Neues.
Julia Schramm, ein Mitglied der Piratenpartei, ist da die...
Ist sehr sichtbar. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sie auch wirklich die einzige oder wesentliche Kraft in der Bewegung darstellt.
Sie war insofern, stimmt also, ob sie da jetzt hinter den Kulissen, wenn die treibende Kraft ist, ist was anderes, ist eine andere Frage, aber sie war sehr sichtbar damals in diesem Spiegel-Interview. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es auch im Print-Spiegel war, weil den lese ich nicht. Es war in dem Online-Spiegel dieses Interview oder dieser Bericht mit dem Datenschutz ist ja sowas von 80s. Das war so der, ich denke, das setzt einfach so diesen Durchbruch, wo das dann quasi aus dieser wir diskutieren mal auf dem Kongress oder in den Kommentaren bei netzpolitik.org rausgebrochen ist zu, okay, da gibt es jetzt irgendwie ein Thema. Vorher wurde vielleicht ab und zu dann, wer da in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht noch zu nennen ist, ist der Jeff Jarvis, der einen, oh man, jetzt lass mich überlegen, ich glaube, Journalismus ist seine oder Publizistik ist sein Lehrstuhl, den er da hat. Also ein amerikanischer Professor oder ich weiß noch nicht, ob er Professor ist, aber Dozent oder was, also sehr...
Journalist und Professor behauptet zumindest die Alwissene Mühlhalde.
Okay. Ein Journalist und Professor, der also auch diese Post-Privacy-Sache lebt und das insbesondere getan hat im Falle seiner Prostata-Erkrankung, dann damit quasi, der hat sich damit auseinandergesetzt, dass er Prostata-Krebs hatte und das irgendwie da relativ öffentlich behandelt und das also gilt so als sein, dann berichtet er davon, das ist seine Lehre, wie er von seinem Prostata-Krebs und er musste windeln und er hat erectile Dysfunktionen und darüber alles relativ offen berichtet hat und das ist so sein Beispiel, was er dann bei Vorträgen so anbringt, dass er sagt, ich habe etwas aus meiner absoluten Intimsphäre genommen und das der Menschheit erzählt und es gab nur positive Reaktionen. Ich werde nicht als impotent verlacht, wenn ich irgendwohin gehe, sondern ich werde als mutig betrachtet und quasi das so als Lehrstück dafür sieht, wie viel Privatheit man nach außen kehren kann.
Ja, für manche ist das ja auch einfach oder für manche ist es einfacher und für andere ist es vielleicht eben nicht so einfach, das zu tun.
Was vielleicht noch kurz zu sagen ist, ist ja dann noch da, also man könnte ja jetzt vielleicht, wenn man sich jetzt das erste Mal mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzt oder wenn man das jetzt zum ersten Mal hört, sagen, ja gut, wenn der Jeff Jarvis das möchte, dass er auf Twitter über seine Prostata-Probleme sich mit den Leuten austauscht, dann möge er das tun und jemand, der es nicht machen möchte, der möge es bitte sein lassen und dann sind wir alle glücklich. Ganz so einfach gestaltet sich das dann leider doch nicht, weil es ja dann eben diese Theorie gibt oder die klare Ansage gibt, wenn ich jetzt nicht selber über eine Prostata-Erkrankung twittere, dann könnte das immer noch mein bester Freund tun, den ich mich anvertraut habe. Also irgendwie so ein bisschen diese, teilweise vielleicht auch noch so ein bisschen von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge. Aber in anderen Fällen, also beispielsweise Überwachung, wer wann wo war, da kann natürlich schon, weiß ich nicht, das Foto, was irgendjemand macht, mich verraten oder sonst was. Und gleichzeitig sich die Debatten immer häufig bei an so neuen Features von Facebook, das sieht man dann immer. Facebook sagt, wir haben jetzt Gesichtserkennung. Und dann kommen die Datenschützer und sagen, das ist aber ganz schlimm, das finden wir nicht gut. Das ist irgendwie eine Überwachungstechnik und ihr schult da Gesichtserkennungsprogramme und jetzt können nicht nur Menschen, nicht nur haben wir eh schon die Situation, dass Personen Fotos von uns auf Facebook veröffentlichen können und uns darin taggen können, sondern jetzt erkennt uns Facebook da auch noch dran und dann kann man dieses Feature irgendwie ausschalten, ja, dann kommen quasi die, wird dann auf Netzpolitik zum Beispiel natürlich auch dann darauf hingewiesen, ok, Facebook macht das jetzt und so und so kann man es wieder ausschalten und dann sagen die, kommt die Sparkeria und sagt, warum habt ihr da vor Angst, das ist total toll, könnt ihr Fotos von euch selber sehen und ihr macht das wieder alles kaputt und die quasi, während die Datenschützer das quasi interpretieren als einen Angriff der Sparkeria auf die Privatsphäre, Sparkeria jetzt mal, also Facebook als Sparkeria gesehen, sehen die, sieht die Sparkeria den Einsatz der Datenschützer dagegen als Angriff auf ihre Freiheit an, ja, das Michael Seemann, du hast ihn gerade schon kurz erwähnt, MS Pro, auch ein, also ich glaube er ist Kulturwissenschaftler und promoviert irgendwie gerade und setzt Ich setze mich auch so mit diesen Ideen der Post-Privacy auseinander. Argumentiert da gerne so oder bringt da so Begriffe in den Raum, wie das radikale Recht des anderen. Und versucht Beispiele zu finden, warum der andere vielleicht ein Recht hätte darauf, warum eventuell es nicht moralisch geboten ist, bestimmte Bereiche in seine Privatsphäre zu ziehen, weil vielleicht die öffentliche Erkenntnis daraus, dass das höhere Gut ist, als das persönliche Wohlbefinden damit, dass man das in der Privatsphäre gehalten hat oder so. Jetzt hab ich gerade kurz den Fahnen verloren. Worauf wollte ich jetzt hinaus? Oh mein Gott, jetzt ist es passiert, Tim.
Ja, das kann ja mal passieren. Ich kann es ja mal mit meinen Worten zusammenschreiben. Die Spakaria betrachtet die Aluhüte als Angriff auf sich und umgekehrt. Du hast jetzt MS-Pro als Vertreter einer eher Pro-Spakaria-Richtung. Er ist da sicherlich auch noch differenziert.
Auf jeden Fall. Was ich eigentlich nur darstellen wollte, ist, dass beide irgendwie das gegenseitig als Angriff sehen auf ihren Bereich. Ein Großteil dieser Debatte zeigt sich auch darin, dass die Überlegung ist, was ist einfach das Default? Ist das Default, dass Facebook dieses Feature für alle aktiviert? Oder sollte das Default sein, dass Facebook den Leuten anbietet, es zu aktivieren? Das Ergebnis ist natürlich ganz klar. Wenn Facebook eine Gesichtserkennung ausrollt, dann haben das die meisten Menschen einfach und schalten es auch nicht ab. Eventuell vielleicht auch einfach aus Unkenntnis oder so. Während wenn es umgekehrt wäre, natürlich nicht so viele Menschen es nutzen würden. Das ist einfach so ein bisschen Trägheit, die da einfach mit drin ist. Da gibt es also viele Debatten drum. Was ich aber darin vermisse, ist eigentlich die Überlegung wieder, dass es eigentlich gar keine Frage des Datenschutzes ist, ob ich bei Facebook meine Gesichtserkennung deaktiviere. Oder ob ich irgendwie, wenn ich auf einem Foto getaggt bin, auf dem ich nicht getaggt sein möchte, ja, wenn ich dann sage, liebes Facebook, ich möchte auf diesem Foto nicht getaggt werden, dann heißt das in der Facebook-Datenbank steht, Linus Neumann möchte auf diesem Foto nicht getaggt werden. Er ist da. Und wenn da jetzt jemand hinklickt, das muss Facebook speichern. Weil wenn nämlich jetzt dann der nächste kommt und sagt, ach guck mal, hier Linus Neumann, tag ich, dann muss Facebook ja sagen, nee, darfst du nicht. Das heißt, so oder so steht in der Facebook-Datenbank drin, dass ich das bin.
Ja, außerdem steht noch drin, er will auch nicht gesehen werden.
Ich gebe den also dadurch, dass ich, ich gebe den nur mehr Informationen dadurch, dass ich sage, ich möchte, ich verifiziere und werte quasi gleichzeitig in diesem Schritt. Ich sage, ja, bin ich. Und zweitens, das ist mir peinlich. Und das heißt, im Prinzip kann man nicht von Datenschutz sprechen, wenn man sagt, man deaktiviert das, weil dieses Feature im Hintergrund eben bei diesem Tagging halt trotzdem läuft. Und ich muss jetzt zugeben, dass ich bei der Gesichtserkennung nicht 100% ich weiß, inwiefern die vielleicht trotzdem mitläuft. Oder ob man tatsächlich, wenn man bei Facebook das Hähnchen setzt, macht bei mir keine Gesichtserkennung, dass er es dann tatsächlich nicht macht. Aber ich denke, das Problem wird deutlich. Es ist im Prinzip keine, also genau genommen oder auch wirklich, ich denke, dass diese Unterscheidung auch wichtig ist. Es ist keine Frage des Datenschutzes, wenn ich bei Facebook-Features deaktiviere, die dann trotzdem im Hintergrund einfach weiterlaufen. Das ist dann eine Frage der Privatsphäre, wunderbar. Aber es ist, denke ich, keine Frage des Datenschutzes. Wenn ich mich wirklich um Datenschutz sorge, dann sollte ich niemals ein Facebook-Profil haben.
Man muss die Datensparsankheit bei einem selbst anfangen. Und nicht bei den Systemen, die man benutzt. Nach dem Motto, hier hast du alle meine Daten, aber Sachs-Kreib.
Vielleicht um noch mal eine Lanze für die Datenschützer zu brechen. Ich glaube, inzwischen ist das jetzt endlich weg. Das war, denke ich, wirklich ein bisschen, ich fand das wirklich auch persönlich als unsäglich, dass bei der Facebook-Anmeldung der Nutzer darum gebeten, wurde doch mal eben kurz sein Gmail-Passwort einzugeben oder sein sonstiges Passwort auf das Facebook, das Adressbuch mal schnell runterladen könnte.
Das ist ja eine Funktion, die man fast überall findet, ja.
Und dann schaut Facebook durch dieses Adressbuch durch und informiert darüber, also informiert erstens die Leute in diesem Adressbuch, die nicht bei Facebook sind, darüber, dass diese neue Person bei Facebook ist. Man könne doch auch dorthin kommen. Und hat gleichzeitig natürlich dann diese ganzen Daten und verbindet einen dann diejenigen, die auf Facebook sind, verbindet es dann automatisch. Hatte für mich als nicht auf Facebook vorhanden sehende Person den ärgerlichen Effekt, dass immer wieder ich E-Mails bekommen habe. Guck mal hier, dieser oder diese jene Person oder diese jene Person ist jetzt auf Facebook. Und übrigens, wer da noch ist, den du auch vielleicht kennst. Diese E-Mail zeigte, dass Facebook bereits, obwohl ich gar nicht deren Nutzer war, Daten über mich hatte. Sie wussten, in welchen Adressbüchern ich war und konnten mir direkt sagen, guck mal hier, Freund A, B, C und D sind auch da. Und die kennst du ja, komm doch auch zu Facebook. Das ist natürlich in der Tat vielleicht eine Datensammlung, die echt nicht in Ordnung ist. Und da haben sich dann auch nach langem Hin und Her hat sich das dann, denke ich, so durchgesetzt, dass das entweder ganz abgeschaltet wurde oder zumindest nicht mehr als Default irgendwie passiert. Also ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher. Aber das wurde auf jeden Fall nach längeren Kämpfen dann abgeschaltet. Aber da, um mal irgendwie zu zeigen, dass es da vielleicht doch ein berechtigtes Interesse der Datenschützer gibt, sich mit so einem Unternehmen auseinanderzusetzen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich klar. Man muss ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer gleich wieder mit der Maximalverschwörung kommen, mit hier sie sind ja hinter uns her und wollen uns ja nur überwachen etc. Was sie sicherlich auch teilweise auch wollen, teilweise auch vielleicht nicht wollen, nichtsdestotrotz. Es ist schon klar, dass natürlich in solchen Datenstrukturen einfach eine Menge Potenzial drinsteckt für Recherchen, die einerseits vielleicht legitim irgendeiner Strafverfolgung tatsächlich dienen können. Das ist ja immer so das eine Ding. Und andererseits eben auch illegitim irgendwelchen anderen denkbaren Verschwörungen oder vielleicht sogar auch kriminellen Angriffen. Weil es ist ja klar, in dem Moment, wo man über komplexe private Strukturen von jemanden Bescheid weiß oder sogar von einer größeren Gruppe, macht man sie natürlich auch angreifbarer. Und das ist ein generelles Spannungsfeld, wie man so schön sagt. So habe ich das beim CCC gelernt, dass man das so nennt. Also CCC Aufenthalt schult ja auch in Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Und ich würde sagen, an der Stelle können wir vielleicht das Thema jetzt in dem Detail auch nochmal einpacken. Das werden wir sicherlich noch häufiger aufgreifen, auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Genau, das sollte ja so ein bisschen dienen als Einführung, wenn wir dann demnächst...
Ja, und vor allem auch so ein bisschen als Übergang zur der Situation Piratenpartei, in der sich ja glaube ich auch genau dieses Spannungsfeld unter anderem ganz gut abzahlt. Das ist sicherlich nicht das einzige Spannungsfeld, was sich jetzt in der Piratenpartei so zeigen wird, aber es ist so das, was jetzt schon absehbar ist. Dass nämlich sowohl Leute, die jetzt eben in dieser einen Richtung als auch der anderen Richtung eher anhängen, beide glücklich mit der Piratenflagge in der Hand da gerade den Einzug in den Berliner Landtag feiern. Und das noch eigentlich überhaupt nicht absehbar ist, in welcher Richtung eigentlich Datenschutz und eben auch viele andere Themen bei den Piraten letztlich behandelt werden. Derzeit herrscht natürlich eine große Euphorie und es ist auch, sagen wir mal, medial. Noch steht derzeit immer noch sehr viel, also sie haben ja noch ihre Schutzzeit, würde man sagen, so diese 100 Tage. Die klassischen dürfen sie jetzt hier wahrscheinlich auch dann mal ausloten. Danach wird dann der Gewittersturm sicherlich über sie kräftig hereinbrechen. Jetzt testet der Journalismus erstmal natürlich, was man draus machen kann, ist natürlich super. Hier Leute im orangenen Blaumann mit Piratenkopf-Tuch und so macht sich schon mal immer super. Und überhaupt die Unkonventionellen. Und guck mal, sie tragen aber auch Krawatten und wie vielseitig sie daraus sind und was nicht alles. Dann hier solche Stunts, dass sie ja jetzt eingeladen worden sind von der besten Partei aus Island. Hast du die Geschichte mitbekommen eigentlich?
Erzähl du die mal, weil ich hab sie nicht ausreichend gut mitbekommen.
Bist du ein Clan über diese beste Partei-Geschichte? Also diese, eine Gruppe von Künstlern eigentlich, die in Island halt nach dieser gesamten Staatskrise, die auch eine kulturelle, politkulturelle Krise war vor allem, die halt angetreten sind zur Kommunalwahl, also zur Wahl des Bürgermeisters in Reykjavík und die halt einen völlig absurden Werbespot gemacht hat, so fast schon wie ein Musikvideo, wir sind die beste Partei, simply the best und la la la und sich da glorios gezeigt haben und dann am Ende tatsächlich zwei Prozent vor der traditionellen Gewinnerpartei lag und tatsächlich jetzt den Bürgermeister stellt. Das heißt, der Bürgermeister ist halt jetzt tatsächlich Künstler und Musiker und die ganze...
Ja und er gehört der besten Partei.
Ja klar, sie sind halt die Besten und die ganze Fraktion besteht aber nur aus solchen Freidenkern, was natürlich eine interessante Konstellation ist. Und als dann die Piraten hier in Berlin so kolossal gewannen mit neun Prozent, stellte man da wohl sofort eine mentale Verbindung her, auch wenn das, glaube ich, ganz anders gelagert ist. Aber am Ende haben die wohl zumindest auch festgestellt, dass es da auch so ein spaßorientiertes Moment ist. Das wird jetzt der Piratenpartei nicht unterstellen wollen oder auch positiv zuschreiben wollen, dass sie jetzt immer nur spaßorientiert sind. Aber das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall ein Moment, zumindest derzeit. Und dann sind halt drei, also der Alexander Moorlangen, Christopher Lauer und der Martin Delius, dahingefahren und haben da irgendwie eine Woche verbracht. Und haben sich dann so von Journalisten begleiten lassen. Wo ich sagen muss...
Anfängerfehler.
Vielleicht wusstet ihr, worauf ihr euch einlasst. Ja, aber hätte ich nicht gemacht. Einfach schon an der Stelle. Da muss man dann glaube ich auch selber ausloten. Auf der einen Seite wollen sie dann halt auch da immer diese Transparenz und so. Was dann vielleicht auch schon mal dazu führt, dass sie eben jetzt auch in aller Öffentlichkeit ihre Schlammschlachten führen müssen. Das mag segensreich sein, das mag desaströs sein, das wird die Zeit zeigen. An sich ist es interessant zu sehen, dass die Piraten überhaupt so weit gekommen sind. Ich glaube, da hat man noch vor einiger Zeit nicht unbedingt mit rechnen können. Der Grund, warum sie jetzt eigentlich in Berlin so gut abgeschnitten haben, ist sicherlich vielschichtig. Auf der einen Seite hatten sie es mit einem kolossal langweiligen Wahlkampf aller anderen zu tun, insbesondere der Grünen, der einfach desaströs war.
Und sie haben dem einen richtig coole Wahlplakate entgegensetzen können.
Das stimmt, also die Aktion war wirklich irre gut.
Die waren spitze. Die waren gut designed, coole Claims drauf. Also das haben sie sehr gut gemacht. Was ich denke, sie haben... Vielleicht für die Nicht-Berliner. Also es gab so schöne Plakate, wie Christopher Lauer hatte irgendwie eins, was hänge ich eigentlich hier, geht ja eh nicht wählen.
Ja, das war überhaupt der Knaller.
Dann gab es irgendwie, trau keinen Plakat, informier dich, solche. Also das war einfach, das war sehr gut.
Ja, in die richtigen Menschen und so.
Ja, das war einfach sehr gut.
Ja, es hat genau den Kern getroffen und es hat natürlich zusätzlich noch... Das wäre jetzt auch so nur in Berlin gegangen.
Ich denke auch nicht, dass das jetzt unbedingt ein...
Das ist eine echte Berliner Nummer.
Ja, ich denke auch nicht, dass das jetzt unbedingt mit Netzpolitik zu tun hatte, dass sie da jetzt gewonnen haben. Das denke ich auch nicht. Das, was da sicherlich eine große Rolle spielte war dieser Transparenzanspruch. Wir hatten ja in Berlin durchaus einige Missstände in Sachen Transparenz in den letzten zehn Jahren. 20 Jahre. Ich überblick erst zehn. Das schien irgendwie ein Aspekt zu sein. Ich glaube, was ernsthaft auch zu deren Erfolg beigetragen hat, war überhaupt die Feststellung, dass irgendwann ja diese Studie war, wo gesagt wurde, die könnten die fünf Prozent schaffen. Und dass das überhaupt erst mal die Wähler oder potenziellen Wähler von der Seite, naja, wenn ich die wähle, verschenke ich meine Stimme, von diesem Ding weggekommen sind.
An dem Moment, wo die erste Fünf-Prozent-Abschätzung kam, war eigentlich klar, dass sie die jetzt auch locker reißen werden. Das war ganz klar. Dann haben die anderen auch noch Angst bekommen und wobereit. Sie haben einfach ganz klassische Fehler gemacht und vor den Piraten gewarnt. Was Dümmeres hat er in seiner ganzen Amtszeit noch nicht hingelegt. Das mag ihm am Ende auch diese von ihm wahrscheinlich ungeliebte Rot-Grün-Konstellation auch vollständig verhagelt haben. Na ja, gut, das wird sich zeigen. Die Piratenpartei dürfte hier auch ein regelmäßiges Thema sein können.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Tagespolitik haben wir noch. Wir können uns jetzt überlegen, ob wir noch ein bisschen in die Tagespolitik gehen wollen oder ob wir sagen, wir machen das beim nächsten Mal und bleiben bei unserem State of the Union. State of the Union, wie Tim das genannt hat.
Ja, worauf würdest du da jetzt abzielen, auf diese Telekommunikationsgesetzgeschichte?
Also ich dachte so ein bisschen, dass dieses, das wäre jetzt halt gerade das aktuelle Thema, dass es diese gab, wo sich auch noch mal so ein bisschen zeigt, was vielleicht gerade, also ich glaube, dass sich da sehr stark widerspiegelt, dass Netzpolitik im Moment nur an den Bereichen irgendwie ernsthaft betrieben wird und streng betrieben wird, wo es irgendwie wirtschaftliche Interessen betrifft und weniger eben diese Bürgerrechtspositionen. Das könnte man jetzt anhand dieser TKG-Novelle illustrieren, aber wir können das auch gerne einfach beim nächsten Mal ausführlich machen.
Naja, wir können das, ich meine, das ist jetzt insofern wirklich auch so aktuell, dass es sich hier lohnt, da vielleicht auch nochmal einen Bogen zu schlagen. Also worauf hälst du jetzt hinaus, auf diese FDP-Nummer, dass sie uns jetzt hier die Breitbandzusicherung?
Ja, also genau, das wäre jetzt zum Beispiel ein Aspekt, also vielleicht kurz zur Erklärung. Es war irgendwie notwendig, dass das deutsche Telekommunikationsgesetz geändert wird, weil es irgendwie ein paar europäische Richtlinien gab, die sich geändert hatten. Deswegen musste das deutsche Telekommunikationsgesetz angepasst werden. Da wurde irgendwie längere Zeit darüber debattiert. Und jetzt ist es gestern, denke ich, entschieden worden. Da sind so Aspekte drin, wie dass man jetzt nach zehn Jahren Kampf der Verbraucherschützer nicht mehr für Telefonwarteschleifen bezahlen muss. Das ist eigentlich sehr witzig, aber ich glaube wirklich, dass das jetzt seit ungefähr zehn Jahren so ein Kampf ist, in dem sich zum Beispiel Verbraucherzentralen irgendwie bemüht haben, dass irgendwie so ein bisschen mehr preistransparenz Sachen und so alles vorgeschrieben werden. Aber das Interessante war natürlich an dieser Novelle, dass da die Gelegenheit gewesen wäre, bestimmte Aspekte der Netzpolitik mit reinzubringen, beispielsweise Netzneutralität, man könnte darin sowas wie Vorratsdatenspeicherungsverbot oder solche Dinge oder eine Regelung für Vorratsdatenspeicherung könnte man in diesem Gesetz unterbringen. Da gibt es also sehr, sehr viel, was man darin hätte unterbringen können. Und eben auch, wie du das gerade sagtest, eine Vorgabe für den Breitbandausbau, dass irgendwie, also es gibt ja auch heute noch Gegenden, in denen keine vernünftigen Internetanschlüsse zur Verfügung stehen. Das hätte quasi in diesem Rahmen gesetzlich geregelt werden können, dass Provider irgendwie verpflichtet sind, auch dahin Internet zu bringen, wo es sich für sie finanziell vielleicht nicht so sehr lohnt.
Ja, Grundversorgung.
Eine Grundversorgung sicherzustellen. Da gab es dann die Grünen, glaube ich, die gesagt hatten, 6 MBit muss einfach in jedem Haushalt verfügbar sein. Haben sie aber nicht reinbekommen, diesen Entwurf. Genauso wurde ein Vorschlag, dass also Netzneutralität festgelegt werden sollte für Internetübertragung, für Internetanschlüsse, hat es da auch nicht reingeschafft. Und was ich denke, was sich da irgendwie so widerspiegelt in dieser langen TKG-Novelle, ich glaube, die ist irgendwie über 100 Seiten, da spiegelt sich so wieder, also es geht irgendwie immer nur, da sind irgendwie klare Regelungen für alles, was irgendwie mit Geldverdienen zu tun hat. Also irgendwie die wirtschaftliche Interessen oder Regelungen, die das Verhältnis zwischen Anbieter- und Verbraucherregeln sind da einfach sehr ordentlich und elaboriert drin untergebracht worden. Da hat man sich irgendwie mit auseinandergesetzt, da hat man sich Zeit für genommen. Und während sowas wie Netzneutralität, Vorratsdatenspeicherung eher Themen sind, die also Bürgerrechte betreffen, also es gibt ja eine, also sag ich mal der Schutz vor einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja ein Interesse, was eigentlich einfach nur einer demokratietheoretischen Überzeugung, einer Bürgerrechtsüberzeugung zuzuordnen ist. Die haben da keine Berücksichtigung drin gefunden. Und das fand ich, ohne jetzt weiter da ins Detail gehen zu wollen, einfach eine interessante Diagnose, dass in diesem lange debattierten Ding letztendlich sich diese Bürgerrechtsüberlegungen einfach, die finden sich da nicht drin. Deswegen als State of the Union fand ich das jetzt ein ganz interessantes Zeichen.
Das ist ein interessanter Vergleich, weil ich denke, man könnte sogar so weit gehen zu sagen, dass das, was der Verbraucherschutz vor 10, 15 Jahren war, dass das so ein bisschen die Situation derzeit in dieser Netzgestaltungspolitik, Netzpolitik ist. Damals hat man auch Verbraucherschutz als wirtschaftsfeindlich erachtet und das wäre doch alles zumutbar und so weiter. Also es war einfach kein Thema. Irgendwann, ich würde mal sagen, Verbraucherschutz, das ist so Bürgerrechte, Alpha-Version. Das ist so das Kleinstzugeständnis. Du darfst nicht verarscht werden. Du musst nicht Scheiße kaufen im Supermarkt. Du musst dir nichts Ungesundes unterschieben lassen. Das Minimum an Garantien in einer technologisierten Welt, dass du nicht durch wirtschaftliche Zwänge über einen Haufen gefahren wirst oder Scheiße verkauft bekommst. Das steckt drin in den Warteschleifen. Das ist etwas, was durch die Grünen, besonders Renate Künast, als Bundesministerin, eine Menge bewegt hat. Jetzt ist das angekommen. Verbraucherschutz, da sagen alle, das ist wichtig, das brauchen wir. Wie Umweltschutz auch jetzt einfach mal Default ist. Jetzt kommen diese abstrakten Forderungen mit Netzneutralität, was super schwer zu erklären ist. Das ist sicherlich auch noch mal Futter für eine kommende Sendung, wo wir eben wie mit dieser Datenschutzgeschichte auch in der Netzneutralität, wie denn das nun genau zu definieren sei, was man damit jetzt eigentlich wirklich meint. Es ist definitiv mehr als eine festgefahrene Meinung.
Da werden wir sicherlich auch nochmal eine eigene Sendung.
Genau, und auch da gab es ja auch schon ähnliche Debatten, wie jetzt mit der VDS da um Alva etc. Und vielleicht sind wir jetzt sozusagen an dieser frühen Geburtsstunde, wo man sagt, okay, in zehn Jahren ist das dann normal, dass solche Dinge auch dasselbe Gewicht bekommen. Aber derzeit, wie du das schon sagst, ist es denke ich schon so, dass das ganze Internet im Wesentlichen als ein Wirtschaftsthema gesehen wird. Interessanterweise ist es das ja auch und wird ja auch von der Netzgemeinde auch so gemacht, aber dann wiederum im Hinblick Chancen. Also die Chancen werden nicht genutzt und die Risiken werden durchgewunken. Da ist es halt einfach mit der, ich glaube auch mit der Erfahrung des politischen Systems noch nicht so weit her.
Ich denke, was...
Generationswechsel steht an.
Also ich würde ja sogar vielleicht echt noch einen Schritt weitergehen. Ich hatte da auf Netzpolitik auch so ein Artikel zugeschrieben, dass ich vor einigen Wochen in Köln diese DMExco oder DMExco Digital Marketing Exposition and Conference besucht habe. Das ist die Fachmesse aller, die sich irgendwie mit Digital Marketing auseinandersetzen. Und das ist eine große Messe in Köln.
Die DMExco Überlebenssurvival in der Einöde des Digital Marketing.
Genau, da habe ich eine kleine Glosse dazu geschrieben, wie meine Eindrücke davon sind. Und was ich darin eigentlich so beschrieben habe, ist, dass es offensichtlich einen breiten Teil der Gesellschaft und auch der Wirtschaft gibt, die dieses Internet nicht als ein, oder vielleicht schon als ein Kommunikationsmedium sehen, aber hauptsächlich als einen Kanal, mit dem sich Geld verdienen lässt. Wirtschaftsraum. Genau, ein Wirtschaftsraum. Darin muss geworben werden, darin muss geguckt werden, dass man sein Return of Investment optimiert, darin muss geguckt werden, wie man da eben seine Schnitte kriegt, wie man da sein Geschäftsmodell drin umsetzt. Und das ist einfach ein besserer Fernseher. Und diese Vorstellung von dem, was Internet ist, die ist offensichtlich sehr verbreitet, während auch, also auch bei den Nutzern, es sind ja bei weitem nicht alle Nutzer jetzt irgendwie, ja, für die es halt Internet ist, da ist Internet dran an meinem Telefon, da kann ich Facebook mitmachen. Und da kann ich auch, weiß nicht, Satu mitgucken oder was auch immer, sodass da auch eine, eine Kons, nicht sehr viele Nutzer eben auch so ein, einfach nur sehr Konsumenten, einfach so eine Konsumentenrolle in diesem Netz haben. Ja, die sehen das als ein, als ein Unterhaltungskanal, in dem sie eine Konsumentenrolle haben, sich aber auch irgendwie beteiligen können. Und das ist, ich kann das selber ganz schwer fassen, weil ich persönlich einfach aus einer ganz anderen Sicht aufs Netz komme. Und ich fand das aber sehr interessant, das mal so zu sehen, dass offensichtlich ist da wirklich einfach so eine, ganz selbstverständlich davon. Als ein Wirtschaftsraum gesehen wird. Und die auch vielleicht wirklich verwundert sind, wenn da auf einmal irgendwie so ein paar Leute ankommen und sagen, ja, aber hier Bürgerrecht auf Netzneutralität, das ist irgendwie, Netzneutralität ist wichtig für die Demokratie, während die sich irgendwie denken, Was ist denn das für digital esotierende? Was ist das denn für einer, der soll doch froh sein, wenn irgendwie für einen extra Kanal so und so, also wie gesagt, ich denke, das Thema Netzneutralität werden wir in einer anderen Sendung dann nochmal ausführlich behandeln. Aber da gibt es wirklich, das ist irgendwie meine Erkenntnis, da gibt es irgendwie auch so nochmal so eine, nicht unbedingt diese Kluft zwischen digital natives und, wie hießen die anderen, also denen, die im Internet geboren sind und ihre Eltern oder so, sondern es gibt glaube ich echt auch so innerhalb der Netznutzer, gibt es einfach so einen Unterschied zwischen, oder so eine Kluft zwischen Personen, die das als einen Wirtschaftsraum sehen und Personen, die das wirklich als einen...
Kommunikations- und Freiheitsraum sehen. Klar, den gibt es ganz klar.
Und also für mich ist das so eine total, also in letzter Zeit irgendwie so eine große Sicht, wo ich dann vielleicht auch jetzt im Nachhinein verstehe, warum eventuell bestimmte Themen, die ich vielleicht mal auf Netzpolitik behandelt habe, warum die nicht gezündet haben, während andere gezündet haben. So, dass man sich denkt, Mensch, das ist doch ein Thema. Das ist doch hier unglaublich. Warum kriege ich so wenig Reaktionen auf diesen Artikel? Warum lesen den so wenig Menschen? Warum zündet dieses Thema nicht ein? Während man bei anderen Themen sieht... Also ich glaube, inzwischen ist der meist kommentierte Artikel auf netzpolitik.org auf dem ganzen Blog, was seit 7, 8 Jahren jetzt gibt, behandelt die Abschaltung von Kinotheo. Der wird heute noch. Jeden Tag landen da Leute drauf und setzen sich damit auseinander. Das war der größte Aufschrei, den dieses Blog jemals produziert hat. Also kann ich jetzt...
Aber zumindest ein messbar großer.
Sicherlich hat dieses Blog ganz andere Aufschrei und politische Einflüsse hervorgebracht. Aber das ist etwas, das erricht heute noch die Gemüter. In diesem Artikel findet heute noch Monate später sind da Debatten, wo die Menschen... Das ist also ein Thema, da war das Kinotheo weg. Das ist irgendwie was, das hat die Leute richtig getroffen. Also für mich ist das eine... Daran sehe ich, verstehe ich jetzt einige Dinge besser, die ich vielleicht vor einem Jahr noch nicht so verstanden habe.
Ja, ich denke, an der Stelle machen wir mal einen Cut. Erstens musst du weg. Zweitens haben wir auch die Stundenmarke, wie schon befürchtet, auch gerissen. Künftig wollen wir uns ein bisschen kürzer halten. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch bedeuten, wir konzentrieren uns dann auch auf wenige Themen. Aber ich denke jetzt am Anfang war es erst mal ganz gut, hier auch so ein bisschen den Ton zu finden. Den haben wir, glaube ich, auch ganz gut gefunden. Wir freuen uns natürlich über Anregungen, auch Hinweise, auch dann immer so über diese hoffentlich Woche. Also zwischen zwei Sendungen, welche Themen ihr denn so für aufgreifenswürdig erachtet. Wir lesen mit auf Twitter. Ich hab mal hier so mi-lnp eingerichtet. Da könnt ihr euch dann irgendwie hinwenden. Oder ihr schreibt halt ganz herkömmlich auch eine Mail. Oder kommentiert das hier im Blog. Ja, noch um was Wichtiges mitzuteilen. Andere Ideen kommen später, ne?
Also für mein jetziges Empfinden, glaube ich, wir haben den State of the Union ganz gut hingekriegt und so ein bisschen gezeigt, was unseres erachtet.
Genau, ich hab jetzt ein paar Sachen, die wir uns hier noch notiert haben, die jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen passiert sind. Also was weiß ich so, die ganze Wikileaks-Problematik der Staatsdrojaner, der natürlich gerade in den letzten Wochen hier eine Menge Folgen gemacht hat. Das ist jetzt hier alles noch ein bisschen, hat hier seinen Raum noch nicht gefunden. Wir werden einfach Zeit brauchen, bis wir die Themen einfach auf einer aktuellen Basis machen wollen. Aber wir wollen jetzt hier nicht einen CIE nach dem anderen produzieren, sondern wir wollen hier einfach uns am aktuellen orientieren und da dann unsere Themen und vielleicht auch potenziellen zusätzlichen Gesprächspartner finden. Das war's, Tim und Linus sagen bis bald bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.